[Music]
okay everybody i am so excited today
because i am joined by graham mctavish
who stars as harold westerling and house
of the dragon how you doing today graham
very very good how are you
i'm doing great i am so excited to talk
to you like the whole world is right now
i am just so invested in this show and
you absolutely kill it in the show um
yeah and it's interesting for people too
to know that harold westerling is only
mentioned in the brooks
briefly was that more exciting for us
you in a sense that anything could
happen with this character i yes in a
word yes absolutely it just allows um a
whole lot of latitude in terms of where
they choose to take the character and uh
what he does and what he doesn't do yeah
so uh pretty much a clean slate which is
uh which is ideal um i mean it was
always one of the the sort of slightly
sad parts of um my role in outlander was
that i knew from the very beginning that
i was going to get horribly murdered by
my nephew
so it was it was it was it was a bit of
a bit of a downer on the first day at
work to know you know two and a half
years later you'd be dead so yeah
yeah so you got open season with this
which is a yeah way less intense thing
you have to deal with so
also what's interesting too is what was
your first reaction when you saw that
each episode has this time jump going on
where
is that something crazy for you to kind
of experience
yeah yeah yeah well um
you know to have uh
two sets of cast
for quite a number of the characters i
mean probably i think at least six
if not more actually i mean and the rest
of the cast age obviously but in a you
know in my case in quite a subtle way
basically i'm um you know i have a
darker beard and then ten years later i
have uh have been i have now but when
ryan talked to me about it
uh he was saying yeah
there's a whole number of people that
age 10 years so we have to get young
versions of them
my immediate honest reaction was
oh no
because
that
can go
really badly wrong
um
it just can
but they have really pulled it off i
mean the two peop the two young people
that play the young renier and young
allison are fantastic and the older
versions of them are equally brilliant i
mean i really wouldn't say i'm not just
saying that they really are amazing so
uh they've they've completely pulled it
off
and and i think that when people see
that change
um they'll be completely on board with
it
oh that's good to hear because i think a
lot of people are falling in love with
this cast now that we're all kind of
like i hope they can live up this big
shoes to fill you know
oh no no they they they fill those boots
with the the interesting thing was that
we started filming with the older
members of the cast
oh
yeah because of the scheduling
we i'm pretty yeah we shot episode seven
first
wow i know insane we shot episode seven
first so we got to know
all of the you know the the older
characters we did loads of rehearsals
with them we got to hang out together
and all the rest of it and then however
many months later
i remember millie and and the the two of
them they just came in
and uh
we were we were in the tent and i was
thinking who are these
young
women
who are they you know what are they
doing here and they were just kind of
hanging around and you get to be quite
sort of protective
you're sort of like but this is our
thing who are these people what are they
doing here um and then of course
very shortly afterwards we started
filming with them and and
you fall in love all over again
basically but in our case it was
reversed
yeah
uh yeah it's it's it was a strange one
but trust me um everything was great
yeah and that's amazing you say that
knowing that each episode is like most
of these are time jumps so you're going
back in the past so was that really
challenging as an actor too to kind of
did you have to touch base about the
character each where you are like well i
mean
i mean the
important thing to remember is they are
playing the same person yeah so
they
uh they have the same journey you know
you you have experienced perhaps
um like in the case of if i was doing a
scene with millie
and i'd already done a scene with emma
who plays her older version
uh
i mean millie has seen the the rushes
and everything like that of those scenes
and has read the scripts and everything
and she's met with emma so they're all
on the same page
i didn't i didn't feel at any point
there was any sort of strange kind of
like oh no
it was only that moment when they came
in the tent i remember we were having
lunch and i looked over and they were
kind of in civilian clothes they were in
their normal clothes and i was sitting
there in a suit of armor and all that
stuff and you're like you feel you feel
a little bit sort of invaded like what
are they what are they doing these
usurpers coming in to take over
and but they were fantastic they were
fantastic so speaking of millie what is
it like as an actor building a
relationship like that where you see
that harold is renero's sworn shield is
how do you prefer that type of
relationship on screen do you guys get
really close or is it something where
you kind of keep a little bit of
distance well yeah that's very good
question actually because i think
they
it is required to some degree to have a
little bit of a distance
i mean i you know have the shocking
revelation that i was
one of the oldest members of the cast
um which is a bit of a bit of a moment
when you when you're sitting around and
you realize good grief
you know all of these people they're
like 18 and 20 and 25
and so they did all the socializing
together
they did all the socializing but i
didn't um which was fine uh and so
really my relationship with her is
i have a professional relationship as
sir howard westerling with raniera
um which which has its own parameters
built in
uh but also i have a kind of a vuncular
relationship
with her and i did you know it was quite
strange i mean millie's a millie's a
very easy person to like you know she's
she's great to be around she's very warm
and generous
and you know there's there's no side to
her she's just very straightforward very
australian very kind of like
cool and uh and we we got on really well
um i would make her laugh she would make
me laugh
uh you know there was a lot of humor in
those scenes together and i think
while you're not playing it for laughs
on screen
definitely not
uh
the fact that you have that relationship
definitely informs
um the way that performance uh carries
on
yeah and i think for people who just
watch episode one it's awesome that the
show starts us seeing this great
relationship between the two of them and
we're all kind of excited to see where
it goes uh yeah
keeping on that relationship topic
though when we see the relationship with
harold with damon already there's a lot
of tension and we even see he's
protecting him from his brother and even
in the premiere
what was it like for you working with
the powerhouse in matt smith across from
you in those kind of scenes
well matt's great to work with um
he really is
uh i don't know if we've had the scene
yet but uh
the wedding there's a wedding scene
and
there was a
i mean i haven't actually seen the cut
of that yet but there was a great moment
of improvisation that matt
threw in
with me
and it worked really really well and
that's that's the kind of person that if
you toss him a ball he'll he'll just be
able to knock it straight back and uh
and that's for an actor that's that's
the best that's the best so um but from
a character point of view i mean i i
really did like map and do like map very
very much personally but
i made a decision early on
it was a little bit the same as my
decision that i made with the hobbit
when i was thinking about bilbo
uh that i decided in the hobbit that
dwalin was one of the few people
who never trusted him
never trusted bilbo
always thought there was something
not quite right about him and i mean it
turned out he was right you know i mean
the guy could vanish and all the rest of
it and everybody
but so i was very distrustful
and in the case of sir harold was damon
i don't think he he likes him at all
no i mean it's
he has a visceral dislike of him
um
and i don't i don't honestly know
whether damon's character thinks about
sir harold westerling enough to have
that kind of feeling towards him i mean
as far as somebody like damon is
concerned with the kind of ego that he
has
uh so harold westerling is essentially
just a functionary at court you know
he's he's uh you know he's a soldier and
a warrior and all the rest of it but he
he he's not of importance to him because
he's not a threat to damon damon's world
of chess
is involving
these other people people like you know
his brother and and his sister and and
otto and all of these other people so
but my point of view was always that
this is a man that i don't trust as far
as i could spit so that's how i thought
i love that too and it's interesting to
hear that for harold because i feel like
the audience probably feels the same way
at this point about david right now and
that was cool that you brought up prior
work that you did and that comes into
this work which i think is awesome and
speaking of the hobbit i love that
you've done the hobbit outlander now the
witcher and now house of dragon i'm
officially nominating you for the
fantasy actors hall of fame so
is fantasy though your favorite genre to
act in or is it actually another one
i i have to be honest i love
watching it i love watching fantasy you
know i was a huge lord of the rings fan
uh you know the the the day that i
walked the red carpet for the hobbit was
one of the happiest days of my life and
um
and to be part of the the the world of
game of thrones which was another show i
loved um i'm i am i'm a pretty big nerd
uh you know in the same way that i know
that henry cavill talks about it himself
that he's a nerd as well and we're both
we were talking about this on set the
other day we're both self-proclaimed
nerds and we're we're happy with that um
i mean we both have an interest in
painting warhammer figures for instance
you know i love i i i just love all that
stuff um but that doesn't mean that i
don't like other things as well i love i
love action movies you know i loved
doing rambo
um
i i would love to do
uh i'm just re-watching battlestar
galactica at the moment the ron moore
version and um
and it really has really rekindled her
desire to do a really great science
fiction project at some point because
that's another genre that i i love i'm
not so interested in kind of courtroom
drama and
hospitals and you know doctor stuff or
you know cop stuff yes
uh villains yes
uh soldiers you know all the rest of it
i'm very i'm kind of i'm kind of almost
simple really in my
it's kind of worrying really but i i do
enjoy them you know yeah no that's great
to hear and i think fans love that too
because we hope that the actors in the
show are loving it as much as we are so
it's great it's cool to hear that yeah
and that's what that's you too as we're
like speaking in this big moment of game
of thrones like
what has it been like for you though
that you are now a part of something
this big that it's appointment
television it's literally the sunday
night event across the world like is it
scaring you a little bit or are you
getting a thing you know what i don't i
don't think it's really sunk in yet if
i'm honest i really don't i really don't
think it has
um
yeah i mean i'm notorious
as as many actors are actually for not
watching the things that they're in
um
you know i i haven't seen
many many many things that i've been in
apart from the premieres of them
and uh
and that's partly a conscious decision
because i'm
i'm so
aware of the process that we went
through making them that it's very
difficult to feel any kind of detachment
you're just constantly critical or
you're remembering oh my goodness i
remember exactly what was happening just
before that that was done i remember
aretha fans making a joke just before
that take over so you it takes you out
of the story a little bit inevitably
because you're there with the nuts and
bolts of the making of it
um
but no i i i mean i love good as me i'd
be mad not to love the popularity of
house of the dragon in the same way that
i've really loved the popularity of of
outlander and the hobbit and and now the
witcher um that these are these are
shows that fans really love uh
and
i've been really lucky
uh because all of them
are tied to an existing fandom
and
the responsibility of doing that
and not screwing it up
you know i mean you try not to think
about it to be honest but i i mean i
know for instance ryan condor one of the
co um showrunners on house of the dragon
a was a massive game of thrones fan a
huge game of thrones nerd a man who
literally sought out george rr martin
when we were doing a pilot together me
and ryan in new mexico went to have
dinner with him because he wanted to
make that connection and then years
later there he is making a tv show
and and i love i love that i love that
that was that was that man's dream
literally his dream
and when i saw him at the premiere i
said you must be so proud
to have achieved this and you and i yeah
it's taking a bit to take it on board
and you know but he he
i mean we're talking
best part of 10 years
that's taking him yeah from from the
very beginning yeah
yeah and i think that's cool too you
mentioned that
it's this baked in fan base so you felt
that pressure it seems like and i guess
you feel this sigh of relief now that
it's universally loved right now right
like oh
yeah i mean um it's crazy you know i've
i've been very aware people have been
letting me know about how it's been
received uh by the fans by by critics
and the numbers and all of that sort of
thing and and it's it's very difficult
to comprehend these sort of things
really uh you know when you when you
come from a background in theater which
was really you know where i started uh
you would perform to an audience
of hundreds a night
and you would feel wow that was great
you know look there was 600 people saw
that performance and the idea of you
know 10 million people
watching something you can't you you
can't comprehend it it's impossible
yeah that that's a good comparison so i
never thought of like that with theater
and a big stage like hbo sunday night
now before i let you go graham uh we see
in the episode for teaser that harold
again is stepping in front of damon
which got me very excited so you know
can you maybe give us like a one word
tease for maybe the next episode or just
kind of describe it like in a way that
would get us kind of excited oh goodness
me oh no um
well in terms of uh
um
confrontations with with damon i mean
with with me
harold's relationship with damon
is always tempered by the fact that he
is
however much just like him personally he
is a member of the royal family
so
i have to
there's
if i use one word to describe
harold generally
it's
containment
he has to contain himself a lot he's
privy to everything and he has to hold a
great deal
in
not necessarily always
but
certainly um
uh with uh with this so i don't want to
keep i'm very loathe to give too much
race
no i think that's perfect and that's
enough for us to kind of just go into
any hints you might have subconsciously
given us without knowing but oh god
graham this thank you so much seriously
and everybody watch graham just crush it
in house of the dragon hbo and hbo max
every sunday at 9 00 pm graham i hope to
talk to you in the future thanks for
joining me man thank you very much mate
my pleasure